so welcome to the afternoon session uh
I'm gonna have the pleasure of
introducing some more of Tony's students
but before that we have a guest uh
unscheduled guest appearance by Pierre
McKenzie
thanks for letting me three minutes of
your time so those of you yesterday who
were at Ian's mounts has talked on three
evaluations uh learned that Steve Cook
had promised a hundred dollars to
whoever
solve the well improved on the lower
bound that we thought we had and uh Ian
and his and and Steve's son James
succeeded in doing that
uh now um Steve is nowhere non-reactive
and what I think Ian did not quite
mention is the the paper uh on tree
evaluation was co-authored by a bunch of
people so I was one of them
and Dustin Weir was one of them Rahul
was one of them and my Braverman were
one of them now as the next of kin to
Steve Cook who's no longer active I feel
that now it's now my responsibility to
to to get to hand out the fifty dollars
so Ian I'm happy to fund you found your
dinner
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
first up we have Morgan Shirley speaking
on how strong is Randomness and
communication take it away all right
thanks uh today I'd like to tell you
about some problems related to
Randomness and communication that me and
Tony have been working on for the past
few years y'all ever heard of Tony
patasi it's pretty cool yeah
okay uh so let me uh
first Define communication complexity
and communication complexity we have two
parties Alice and Bob Alice gets some
input X Bob gets some input y
they exchange messages According to some
protocol
with the goal of computing some joint
function on their inputs
um
and we say such a protocol is efficient
if a poly logarithmically many bits are
sent a poly logarithmic in the length of
the inputs
so we're interested in randomized
communication complexity here I'm going
to give Alice and Bob access to some
source of randomness
and I'm going to let them make some
errors when they're Computing uh their
function they just have to compute the
function correctly with high probability
uh you might sometimes see this phrased
as shared Randomness instead of private
Randomness link like I've drawn it I'm
not going to uh worry about the
distinction in this talk
okay there are many beautiful results
about randomized uh communication
complexity and there's no way I could
list them all so I've I've taken the
time to list a couple areas that have
been worked on by Tony and people who
have been advised by Tony
um so uh in the standard bounded uh
error communication uh randomized
communication model we don't have a
tight lower bound technique but for some
stronger models we do have tight lower
bound techniques uh and of course we
have a very rich literature in queered
communication lifting um I've listed
three here that uh
relate to randomized protocols and there
are many others
um the um and and uh
other models
um
but one thing to highlight is that there
are a lot of things that we don't yet
understand about the role of Randomness
and communication and here are a couple
examples uh one is uh how strong are
Merlin Arthur protocols um so this is
where we in addition to having
Randomness we have some source of
non-determinism
we also don't really understand the
power of one-sided error so if I only
let you make false positives and no
false negatives what can we do that uh
like well how does that restrict us
compared to two uh cited error
and I have papers with Tony in uh both
of these
today I'll be mostly focusing on some uh
Recent research that we've been doing
um
relating to communication with more than
two parties
so let's add a third party and how do we
generalize the two-party communication
model to three parties
well maybe kind of the obvious thing to
do is say okay in the two-party model
each party can see one input so let's
just
extend that to three parties uh Alice
and Bob still have their inputs X and Y
and we give our third party Charlie uh
some input z uh this is the called the
number and hand model
but kind of an equally valid way to
generalize two-party communication
complexity is you say okay in two-party
communication each player cannot see one
input
and uh the generalization of this is to
have three inputs and each party can see
two of the inputs this is called the
number on forehead model
uh you can think of it as if uh each
party has their own input written on
their forehead so everyone else can see
it except for them
um and this might not seem like the most
natural generalization of two-party
communication uh but it turns out that
there are
um a lot of applications to other fields
that uh getting strong lower bounds on
number on forehead uh communication
would give us
um one of these is uh paper by being
potassium y'all heard of this Tony
patasi she's pretty cool
um where lower bounds on number on
complexity lead to lower bounds improved
complexity
um in this talk we'll talk about uh
applications to additive combinatorics
and I said we were talking about
Randomness so the first question of
course is can we separate randomized and
deterministic number on forehead
complexity
uh and the answer is yes
um
this this is a result of uh Tony and
Paul and uh two others
uh
where there are these functions called
graph functions in a graph function
um one of the Players let's say the K
player
um can look at the other K minus 1
inputs and know what input
he has to have in order for the output
to be one
um and uh by accounting argument there
are graph uh functions that are hard to
compute deterministically but of course
every graph function is easy with
Randomness uh one of the Classic results
in communication complexity is that the
equality function is easy for Randomness
um and of course that means that the
player who cannot see XK can simply do
the two-party equality uh protocol with
any other player to see if they have the
right input
but it's an open question which graph
function
is is hard to commute compute
deterministically
so this is an interesting situation
uh one candidate
um is the exact land function
um so in the exactly and function uh the
inputs I'm going to interpret as numbers
between 0 and n and I want to know if
the inputs sum to n
so this is a graph function and
therefore it has an easy randomized
protocol and uh we don't know an
efficient deterministic protocol
but we do interestingly know that it's
not maximally hard
so for me maximally hard would be
um
uh order log n Bits because uh
kind of a trivial protocol is just uh
someone and now uh announces to one of
the players what their input is and then
they can solve the whole function
so exactly n can be done with less than
uh log n Bits of communication
and this is a result of Chandra person
Lipton in the in the paper where they
introduced the number number on forehead
model
they said okay let's look at the view of
one of these players Alice here can see
and puts Y and Z she doesn't know what x
is but she can compute the value of x
uh that she would need to have in order
for exactly M to be true so let's call
this x Prime similarly Bob can compute y
Prime and Charlie can compute Z Prime
so we have these three values
um and I'm going to let Delta refer to
the uh the
um
like how far away the sum X Plus y plus
Z is compared to the Target value of n
and we can observe that each of these
players their guess is off by exactly
this value Delta
so the idea of Chandra person Lipton
is to Define this new Target value T
which is X plus two y Plus 3z
and then it uh none of the players of
course can compute this because they
don't know all three inputs but they can
compute given their guesses
uh how much uh the value of T is and
you'll notice that their guesses for
what this value T is is off by some
multiple of Delta
uh and so the key Insight here is that
these three values
uh comprise a three-term arithmetic
progression where an arithmetic
progression is a sequence where all of
the values are equally spaced and I'm
going to call such a progression trivial
if uh
they are trivially equally spaced I.E
they're all the same uh value
um
so
these three values comprise a three term
arithmetic progression always and
furthermore that progression is Trivial
if and only if Delta is equal to zero
but of course this is exactly uh
uh this this occurs exactly when the
exactly end function on these inputs
evaluates to one
and so what we've sort of done here is
we've taken this
three-party number on forehead uh uh
situation and we've reduced it to a
three-party number in hand situation
where instead of the original inputs
they have these uh newly calculated
inputs
um and this is sort of a numbered hand
equality we want to know if all the
inputs are equal
um but we have a promise here we we have
a promise that the inputs uh comprise a
three-term arithmetic progression
um
I wanted to briefly mention I I said
that there were connections to added of
combinatorics
um and it turns out that this this
number in hand equality with the Kap
promise uh problem like protocols for
this exactly correspond to colorings of
the numbers between 1 and N such that no
color has uh K term arithmetic
progression and this uh
number on forehead exactly n problem
corresponds exactly to
um something called a corner free
coloring I'm not going to Define this
but it's a closely related concept to
um arithmetic progression free colorings
um and I would be remiss to not mention
that um a connection between uh
arithmetic progression free colorings
and Corner free colorings uh was
previously known by itin semoretti
before
um change a person whipped and connected
this to uh communication complexity
okay
um so moving back to the exactly end
problem
um there's this construction of Baron
from the 40s
um that the the numbers between 1 and N
have a three-term arithmetic progression
free coloring with uh two to the order
square root log n colors um and so if
I'm going to uh communicate
uh the uh a given color it's only going
to take the order Square log n Bits
which is better than my maximal order
log n Bits
um so this shows that exactly n for
three players can be solved using uh
better than maximal communication
this is just what I said
um but this is this is sort of an
existential protocol Baron has a very a
very existential flavor
um there's a there's a lot of like
pigeonhole arguments and stuff
um and so it doesn't give us like an
explicit protocol that we can write down
until the players exactly what to do
um this uh situation was remedied in
2019 by lineal potassium tribe and y'all
ever heard of this Tony potassium she's
pretty cool
um
and so but why do we care about this
explicit protocol I mean this this thing
that I've said up top says that such a
protocol exists uh why why do we care
um and the reason is that if we look at
the details of the protocol that lineal
potassium tribeman wrote down we can
actually find improvements and these
improvements then translate back to
improvements in additive combinatorics
um so
um this is a paper of lineal and
tribeman
um quickly followed up by a paper of Ben
green which are the current best
constructions uh for Corner free colors
um
okay so let me mention ongoing work with
uh Tony and also um suhail Sharif ADI
shriveman and lyanna humbardzuma
um
the the first question that we looked at
was um okay so we have these explicit
protocols that Max match Baron's
construction there's this construction
of Rankin from 1961 which gets uh
which gives a an arithmetic uh
progression free coloring for uh greater
than three
um points and
um we wanted to know if
um we could give an explicit protocol
that matches Rankin's construction and
we can this is uh this is in preparation
uh we also wanted to know if we could
get um improvements in the style of
lineal shridman and green for this K
greater than three case in fact we can
it's in preparation we also have some
ideas connecting this to uh other
problems in combinatorics
um the of course big open problem is
that if we could get strong lower bounds
for these Corner presets
that would lead to a separation between
deterministic uh communication and
randomized communication and the number
on forehead setting
all right thanks everyone
thank you Morgan uh any questions from
the audience
[Music]
not today
all right so those are we see those as
lower bounds those those uh correspond
to lower balancing communication
complexity
um so what that shows is this um
I I said back here that this this number
on in hand the quality problem was
tightly correlated with the uh
the
um arithmetic progression for recoloring
um so what this shows is that um it is a
lower bound on this number in hand the
quality
uh problem uh but only for k equals
three uh they don't know how to extend
the results for K greater
um and that sort of means that
um doing this reduction from the exactly
end problem to number hand the quality
of a promise can only do so well
um if we wanted to give a
asymptotically better
um
exactly and protocol we would have to
use different ideas
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
according to my cheat sheet my next
speaker is Adrian sure
thank you
um can I can I begin okay
hi
um good afternoon everyone my name is
Adrian I'm a student at the University
of Toronto and I will talk about
um how Tony has influenced my
um my experience as a PhD student
so um I first met Tony
um during as many of her grad students
did during The Graduate visit days
offered at the University of Toronto
um in 2018 so at that time I was
completing my undergraduate studies at
UBC
um so I I do remember that when I first
met Tony she said that I had an
interesting background so I'm not sure
what what prompted that but that that's
always kind of been stuck in my mind
since then
um
um but um at that time I knew that I had
a had an interesting complexity Theory
it's it's the subject I enjoyed the most
during my undergraduate studies and um
but I had no specific like most
beginning graduate students had no
specific research program that that I
wanted to work on
um
and so
um I you know decided to I wasn't really
looking forward to moving from the
relatively mild weather on the the west
coast to Toronto with minus 20 degree uh
Winters but uh I was
[Music]
um
motivated by the the strong reputation
of the the TCS group at um at Toronto
and and eventually made the move
so I started seriously working with Tony
as a master's student in January 2019
and
um I'll now describe sort of the the
first problem that that sir we we worked
on together
so as Ian sort of introduced yesterday
uh you know one of Tony's interests is
the idea of composition theorems
so
um given a functions f and g and some
complexity measure see a composition
theorem would show that the complexity
of the composed function is approx not
too different from the
um complexities of the original
functions and by combined together in
some appropriately
and this has motivated much work in
query complexity circuit complexity
communication complexity um Etc
for instance um there's this famous KRW
conjecture which um if this complexity
measure is is the depth of a Boolean
formula then
um if this was true it would show that P
is not equal to to nc1
so at the time there was a postdoc um
Bernard Kumar
[Music]
um
and Tony were interested in in looking
at these problems in the algebraic
setting
so um I'll I'll go into what that means
in a minute but um sometimes it's
believed that the algebraic setting is
is often nicer to prove lower bounds in
compared to to the ordinary Boolean
setting
and so um the specific question that we
were looking at was
um you know given polynomials F and some
set of polynomials GI
if the polynomials F and GI require a
large formula size then must the post
formula where instead of variables x i
we substitute GI does this composed
polynomial require a large formula size
as well so
um one can think maybe this is too
difficult because we don't have generals
or lower bounds on algebraic formula
size but we can look at this in in
restricted settings as well where
instead of looking at general formula
size we look at for instance multilinear
formula sites and where you know in that
case we have super polynomial lower
bounds for polynomials such as the
determinant
so this was really my first introduction
to complexity of theory research and
being presented in this problem and
discussing this with Tony and Bernal
and I was really out of my depth to be
honest
I I had no clue what to do except maybe
um
research and read carefully what
previous papers on in this area
um but um I thought about this problem
with them for for a few months and I
believe it's still open in this original
form
uh
any other questions
okay
so
um
we we actually Manon and I um you know
eventually
um
kind of solve this problem but under
under some some additional assumptions
which is uh I mean for the sake of time
my moments moments um Define this this
nicest condition but we we showed some
form of the composition theorem under
under some assumptions on on the inner
polynomials
and in in this um this work
and uh as you you can notice
um you know we we talk about the family
of sure polynomials in this um this
paper
um which is a family of polynomials
that's that has a lot of applications
and combinatorics and um other areas
such as Quantum information Theory so it
was um even though you know we struggled
for for a long time to to you know solve
our original problem I think it was nice
that
um we eventually maybe shifted our
perspective and um and came up with this
result
um so this brings us sort of to the end
of 2019 where
um I needed to to take some courses in
order to to complete my my master's
degree
and um at the time Tony was teaching the
course on ethics and AI with Richard's
ml
and so I decided to you know I my main
interest is is you know mathematics and
TCS but I ended up deciding to enroll in
the course in order to to broaden my
skills and you know due to my my
personal interests um
in uh social justice
and um
to be honest I don't remember much
but um I do remember I think it was an
enjoyable experience and I think it was
uh nice to see how mathematics can be
applied to have to have a social impact
so
um
so now is 2020 and
um I finished my masters and began my
PhD studies and soon after the the
pandemic started
as as we all remember
and so
um during this period uh we started
having uh weekly Zoom meetings with with
our research group in order and in order
to keep in touch with members
and um I remember at the beginning of
the the pandemic it really did create a
sense of community and a sense of
routine
um especially you know when when this
was really the only method to keep in
touch with others at that time and uh it
was it was nice to hear what what other
students were working on in in a group
that had very diverse research interests
and eventually Zoom fatigue sets in so
uh we as as many of you probably have
experienced so we we stopped having
these meetings
but it was fun while it lasted
so um now I'll talk a little bit about
what I worked on with with Tony during
during the covet Years A lot of these
are I think
um unfinished projects but um there
um most of these projects are related to
the field of algebraic proof complexity
and my main interest in in this um
area started because
um as in many 20s of Tony's Works she um
she shows that a lot of algebraic group
systems such as polynomial calculus
Charlie Adams Sons of squares are are
related to to Natural families with
algorithms for solving combinatorial
problems for instance I'm in the Cheryl
Adam system is is really related to
linear programming and the sum of
squaresproof system is related to
semi-definite programming
so by understanding the proof systems
you'll then understand algorithms that
that use these techniques
and you know there's a lot of
applications
um
of these techniques in in machine
learning and Quantum information so I
wanted to maybe do something that would
sort of bridge the gap between abstract
proof complexity and
and these more practical applications
um so one of the first things that we
did was
um to read read some papers of other
grad students and have discussions over
zoom and one of the first things that we
looked at was this
um this idea of automatizability
so um many of you will
know the definition of automatizability
which is that a proof system is
automatizable if there exists a uh
algorithm algorithm that's given the
formula f produces a proof in that
system in time polynomial and the length
of the shortest proof of that formula
and there was a breakthrough paper by
Teresa Mueller in 2019 showing that um
automating resolution is NP hard
and so
um you know we were really inspired by
trying to understand this breakthrough
at that time and uh inspired to see if
we could show that other
um algebraic crew systems were hard to
automate under
um under the same assumptions in
particular we were very interested in
the sum of squares proof system with
Noah Fleming
I don't think he's here but
um we had a lot of Zoom meetings
um but you know we again we know we
spent we spent some time I'm discussing
this for a few months and um you know we
we were able to have some ideas but you
know it it is still open to the best of
my knowledge
um other things we tried to understand
were bounded over critic
um I remember having again having Zoom
meetings trying to
discuss this with with other graduate
students like like Noah
um and maybe it's because I prefer
algebra a lot more than mathematical
logic that I know is never really able
to understand it deeply
but
um at least we tried
and also we we
um we're looking at this this paper of
ikai that showed that
um the I'm given an axiom scheme that
contains the mod P counting principles
and it's not possible to derive the mod
Q counting principle in um
in ACC orfege
um whenever the primes p and Q are
different
um and this this work is particularly
notable since it uses
um representation theory of the
symmetric group
which I I also had been interested in
but
um again I think
um we we tried for a few months and then
and then maybe gave up after that
um
yeah I mean I guess the proof was
simplified from this model Fury thing to
to more combinatorial proof but I think
we we wanted to understand the original
approach
um
but um yeah but finally we had a
successful project
uh which was this uh this result about
tensor isomorphism that that Josh uh
mentioned earlier today
so um this equation maybe looks a bit
ugly on on First Sight but
um we say that um two tensors TNT Prime
um are are isomorphic if there are
invertible matrices X Y and Z such that
this um this equation holds for all
possible indices
um it might look very very unnatural at
first but you know this is actually a
problem that that physicists care about
in in Quantum information Theory
and many problems in algebraic
complexities such as group isomorphism
are reducible to cases of of the tensor
is symbolicism problem
um and as as you can see it's it's
naturally amendment to to studying in in
terms of the proof complexity approaches
since it is already written as a system
of polynomial equations
and um so in um work to to appear with
with Tony
um Nicola galacia and Josh grochow and
as Josh mentioned earlier today we
studied a lower bounds for an upper
bounds and for cancerous morphism in
polynomial calculus which I think was
was an interesting experience
um so
I think to conclude
um I think I've learned a lot from Tony
working with with her over the years um
I think I've taken a keen interest in
concrete models of computations such as
query models communication models proof
systems
um I think largely as a result of
working with people with her
um also an interest in algebraic methods
and techniques with you know many
applications of areas such as Quantum
information and combinatorics
um I've learned the importance of you
know trying trying to have broad
research interests and to try to bring
people from from different backgrounds
um I have some other projects in Quantum
information Theory and although
um although maybe sometimes I had
difficulty explaining them to Tony I
think Tony was was always interested
whenever whenever I brought them up
to discuss them with her
um and I think something I'm still
trying to learn is to to not be afraid
to work on difficult problems and not be
discouraged when
um when you come into barriers during
research
um I think Tony is is always very
optimistic when we discuss research
together
but
um but maybe maybe I I'm maybe trying
trying to try to emulate that as much as
I can
um she is always welcome and inviting
even even as as a beginning graduate
student and um I think
um you know you can learn a lot I think
you learn a lot of non-trivial things in
the research projects process even if it
ultimately fails to solve the intended
problems uh thank you Tony I um it's
unfortunate that I think most of our
time together would have spent over Zoom
but
um I hope I look forward to our future
collaborations thank you
[Applause]
foreign
any questions
you never really tried to get the money
composition theorem for monotone
circuits yeah I never thought about that
but yeah maybe it's for a reason
Arizona
becomes easier uh
[Applause]
I think so
do you think this could actually happen
I haven't thought deeply good enough
about that so maybe
so just just as a clarification in the
composition
did you take different G's on on
distinct inputs or for the same inputs
sorry I didn't hear your question
uh I was asking but I was asking whether
the jeans when you do the composition of
SMG are you thinking of G over distinct
set of inputs
um she could be the same set of inputs I
mean the different G's do they share
inputs or and they could possibly share
it but I see okay so it's kind of like
not like block compositions
right but in in the application we're
looking at they could share share the
statement but
any more questions
all right thank you again
[Applause]
so we have one more speaker for this
session I believe uh which is Elliot
Krieger
you know if that's in person or online
so
questions
awesome
because it sounds
cute
thank you
front right
okay
um hi everyone so I'm Elliot Krieger I'm
calling in from Toronto today to wish
Tony a happy birthday I wish I could be
with you to celebrate in person but
thank you Ian for inviting me to
contribute
so I first got to know Tony during grad
admissions season
um and I was considering coming to
University of Toronto and I had some
other options as well
and as I'm sure all of you know the idea
of making a big decision like this is
very nerve-wracking these graduate visit
days
really take a type of gravity in your
mind and you have to Envision like could
I be a home for myself in this new place
and
um ultimately I think I actually met
Tony over a Skype call after I visited
Toronto and I was feeling uncertain
about that question I didn't
I I knew a lot about the strength of
machine learning at Toronto the fact
that they were building up a new
Institute for uh deep learning and other
related machine learning research
so I could see the sort of a research
excitement was there that overlapped
with my interests was there but I'm
actually a bit of a machine learning
Outsider myself I came from an
engineering background
um
I'm a little bit nervous nervous about
going into this large University into a
new field that there might be uh only
let's say a deep learning Bros for me to
to work alongside and
you know my discussion with Tony was
really refreshing and I felt so invited
and welcomed to the department through
speaking with her and she really
assuaged those concerns
um
yeah you know I had read her papers for
at least a year before I applied to a
PhD program
so I was very aware of her work on
fairness and so it was also like very
cool for me to meet a superstar in the
field and to pick her brain on some
questions I had about the direction of
research going forward
um but that was my initial impression
somebody who is very humble very
welcoming and believes in community
building as a sort of a pillar of
research
and also has a different perspective on
some of these topics in machine learning
coming from theoretical computer science
which is uh
a bit like magic to me actually even
still
um but I was excited to work with her
and that was one of the things that
really convinced me yes this is the
right place for me to do my PhD so you
know I arrived in Toronto and we started
doing research together right away
running into a lot of latex compile
errors but also going through the
process of meeting regularly with a
group of collaborators in this case we
had set up some weekly meetings with
myself Dave Madras rich and also tamani
we kind of formed a little team together
and those meetings were so fun for me
and still getting my
sort of two feet starting on the ground
to do machine learning research
um
but also
you know having discussion with a
theoretical computer scientists who
could
um give us different perspectives but
also like show us a bit of vulnerability
and the sort of curiosity and
inquisitive uh impulse that really I
think drives good researchers
um Tony would ask us very basic and
foundational questions
um about the role of data in machine
learning how it automates decisions what
sort of biases and
concerns around discrimination we might
have when it comes to deploying machine
learning in the real world
and we did a lot of translation work
together Tony was really good at this
asking difficult questions which kind of
cut to the foundational assumptions of
machine learning and helped me to
clarify my own thoughts about the
promises and potential limitations of
machine learning as a sort of a
methodology
um
yeah it's a very engaging first year or
two as a young researcher at U of T
fortunately that we we really got into a
sort of a productive swing and started
turning out some papers that And
discussing our ideas with the fairness
community at large as I feel just so
fortunate to have had a mentor
um
like Tony to help me guide me through
that process and
you know developing some of the
expertise In fairness brought us some
really special opportunities so the one
I think I will remember the most fondly
is our trip to Kigali Rwanda where we
brought some of these research topics
and algorithmic fairness but also in
differential privacy and where Tony is
clearly a world-class expert and we
taught these topics in a seminar course
to
roughly 30 Master students at the
African Institute for mathematical
Sciences like I mentioned in Kigali
um and that was again a sort of
Illuminating experience around
centered around
asking questions curiosity challenging
basic assumptions because
we brought
our sort of pedagogical teaching
framework how we wanted to teach these
topics into the classroom and we're
faced with the limitations of our
abstractions you know we as computer
scientists working in abstractions
that's a blessing and a curse for us it
allows us to make make progress on on
problems but also it can distance our
contributions from what's going on in
the real world and so the students were
able to help us
let's say you know understand some of
the limitations of working with binary
classification binary sensitive
attributes working in a
sort of Frameworks that really have a
lot of inspiration from uh legal case
law in the U.S which is again very
specific to the United States
um so questions around you know what
what are these fairness concerns and
discrimination concerns we should care
about across not just the U.S and Canada
context but across the whole world
it was a great experience so we also had
a lot of fun so here are some pictures
from our trip to Kigali you can see our
own
you can see our our students there on
the top left Tony was incredibly popular
so she was leading the Privacy aspect of
the course and she was I think our most
sought after selfie
um
the person you know students really love
Tony
um and I could see Tony in the same way
that I felt sort of welcomed and
encouraged as a machine learning
Outsider at the beginning of my PhD I
could very clearly see Tony extending
those same words of encouragement
genuine interest in the student's life
outside of the classroom she brought all
of those elements to the course I think
it was a really great experience for
everybody involved we had a chance to do
some
so go on Safari and do some and see some
nature as well so yeah really wonderful
experience so I'm grateful to to Tony
for the chance to work together in a
research capacity but I think more
importantly just for giving me a
grounded sense of being truly social
nature of this profession
um
the importance of building Community the
importance of
empowering and encouraging Junior
researchers so
um yeah Tony happy birthday it's easy
for us to count the
rotations around the the Sun the years
um and marking the anniversary of our
birth but I I couldn't possibly count
the number of lessons that I've taken
from just our short time togethers and
I'll be very happy to pass those along
to my students in the future so happy
birthday I hope everybody enjoys the
celebration thank you to the organizers
for putting this together and I hope to
see you all soon
um I would ask for questions but I don't
think the answers were re-recorded
um I think at this point we can adjourn
for another break and we'll come back at
four o'clock
foreign